all right tuck yeah tuck oh where are
you from originally where'd you grow up
where's that uh it's near Bangkok it's
not far okay and tell me about how you
grew up you had both of your parents
yeah
I have both good childhood yeah
how far did you go in school
um
it's not far but
how many years did you go to school
how many years
10 or 15. okay
and when did you start working as a
prostitute
when did you start doing sex work
just
four months four months ago
before New Year oh really last year so
very recent yeah how old are you
39 39 yeah
so you started you're starting late yeah
well why did you decide to do this at
this age because now my mom she got a
chronic
he'd need this
your mom is sick yeah
and you're helping with the medical
expenses hmm
so you have to do this yes
this is not your choice to do this
how does it affect you
I mean mentally
does it affect you in any way mentally
to be doing this kind of work
I mean you're doing it for a good cause
yes
is that how you see it is there another
option for you to make money
like this yes this is the best money a
woman can make yeah in Thailand
and
I work this because I have time when I I
want to go to the home
I want to bring my mom to the hospital
yeah
yeah too easy
this gives you the freedom to take a day
yeah
and you're making good money when you're
working
so you work in a club
in the Nana Plaza
where the whole Plaza is full of sex
clubs basically
yeah
tell me about uh that working in the
club
what kind of guys come in there
many
different
a lot of tourists yes is it all tourists
yes all tourists all tourists the local
no high men do not go there yeah
why did they not go there
why do the locals not go
too expensive
um
no the cat I was outside
don't let them know if they let them in
yeah
so if you get Americans Australians
Europeans
the guy sees you up on the stage
picks you out
and then you guys do what you go to a
room sometimes
or you go to his hotel yes oh I see
and you'll have sex and come back and do
it again with someone else right
sometimes have sex sometimes not really
yes
just hang out yes and talk and yes
that's nice
you guys are nice
[Music]
yeah what kind of experiences do you
have I mean
tell me about the kind of guys who come
in do you think they're married
sometimes
yes
yeah
there is do uh
I think a lot of guys come out here just
to have sex no no no
some some just want to talk
and drink Hangout
I was there last night the whole
the whole Plaza is full of guys yeah
he's looking for action
what have you learned about men in your
months doing this
I know have you ever been married no
have you ever been in love
no no
what are your hopes for your future
obviously that your mom survives yes but
for you personally what hopes do you
have would you like to get married have
children
no
but maybe falling in love getting
married is that something you you would
want to do
um
maybe maybe
does this kind of work affect you
emotionally do you get depressed or do
you get
angry or frustrated or
anything yes yeah
it's hard to be selling yourself I take
it
is it difficult to be selling yourself
to men is that the most difficult part
of this
you'll make how much money for a date
oh
so so quiet
maybe yes
500 1000.
I'm sure your mom appreciates what
you're doing for her it's a very nice
gesture
do you talk to her about it no
no does she think you're doing something
else yes oh really so she doesn't know
how you're making your money yeah
in Thailand what possible ways does a
woman have to make money
could you have gone to school to be a
lawyer or a doctor or anything like that
you could have yeah but that didn't
happen for you
have you traveled outside of the country
have you been anywhere I've been to
Germany
for three months oh
what do you think of Europe what do you
think of Germany
is
beautiful
it's a great country much colder though
yes
do you love Thailand
us yeah you like it here yeah
what are the biggest problems that you
see for for the Thai people I mean is it
difficult to make a living is it is
difficult
to find a job when you were
older order
yeah
most of the girls working at the club
are
much much younger they're 20 years old
25 years old
you look very young for your age
but um at the Nana Plaza there's so many
girls
they're too many how many girls work at
your Club
okay
50 girls yes yeah
so much competition
and how much money do you make in a
night
um
Maybe
five
hundred
one thousand
a lot
US Dollars no Thai baht yes
so 500 to 1000
bot
which is only about thirty dollars
cost of living must be very low here
what dreams did you have did you have
any dreams in your life to do something
yes yes what did you want to do I want
to go Tempo
you wanted to go to the temple yes to do
what
you wanted to do something
with your religion
yes
What stopped you from doing that
yeah
[Music]
my
said uh
empty no thinking
you made some bad decisions when you
were younger yeah don't we are
what do you do with your free time when
you're not working
[Music]
go out to see you meet a friend
you have friends yes that's nice
are your friends sex workers as well
do they work at the club
used to
but now
to have fun
boyfriend okay
is it difficult I mean do you what do
the girls say amongst each other I don't
think any of the women are enjoying
these guys that are coming by they're
just doing it for the money
most of them are doing it for their
families
yes
seems like everyone I've spoken to is is
working and sending the money to their
family yes
what are you afraid of now what do you
worry about
[Music]
um
I worry about
just not just my mom yeah just your mom
because maybe she can stay just two men
or three months
do you live with your mom
she lives with others ah yes my brother
your brother yeah
yeah does your brother know what you do
no no one knows this is your secret
Taco would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
I think
[Music]
don't worry about everything but
just enjoy
all right talk thank you so much for
sharing your story yes
yes I wish your mom the best of luck
and to you as well
thank you very much